♪ ♪ ♪
- Ça a été un deux mois
de longue haleine,
un travail de dur labeur,
jour et nuit, même.
Ça a été des émotions,
des larmes. C'est comme
une pression qui se relâchait
de savoir qu'enfin, il mettait
les pieds sur l'avion,
puis s'en venait vers le Canada.
- Celui qui est dans l'avion,
c'est le Dr Abdul Wali,
un chirurgien afghan
qu'Hélène LeScelleur a connu
en Afghanistan lorsqu'elle était
en mission avec les Forces
canadiennes à Kandahar,
en 2008.
L'été dernier, alors que les
talibans prenaient le contrôle
du territoire afghan, le Dr Wali
a fait comme des milliers
d'autres et tenté de s'enfuir,
sans succès.
C'est pendant cette période
qu'Hélène LeScelleur a décidé,
avec des collègues, de tenter
de sauver son ami médecin
et sa famille.
HÉLÈNE LESCELLEUR, capitaine à
la retraite, Forces canadiennes
- Le désir de vouloir aider
le Dr Wali, en fait,
c'est surtout du fait que
lorsqu'on a pu être... côtoyer
une personne qui a un coeur
comme celui-là, puis qui avait
vraiment, t'sais, le désir
de faire beaucoup pour autrui,
bien aujourd'hui, on le sait
que c'est lui qui a besoin
de soutien, donc maintenant,
je dois contribuer à aider,
dans le fond, cet homme-là.
Salut les amis! Je suis
capitaine Hélène LeScelleur...
- Hélène LeScelleur était,
à l'époque, officier responsable
des cliniques médicales
des Forces canadiennes
sur place, ce qui l'avait amenée
à rencontrer le Dr Wali.
- Dr Wali est très, très inquiet
de parler au téléphone
parce qu'à chaque fois,
comme il dit : "Je sais pas
qui est autour, qui peut
m'entendre."
- Pour des raisons de sécurité,
la capitaine à la retraite
ne communique avec lui
que par textos cryptés.
Après avoir raté l'évacuation
par avion à Kaboul, le Dr Wali
a dû rebrousser chemin avec
sa femme et ses sept enfants
vers Kandahar, le plus
discrètement possible.
Il a ensuite réussi à se rendre
dans la Ville frontalière
de Quetta et après des semaines
d'attente, il a pu faire
la longue route en bus
avec sa famille vers la capitale
pakistanaise.
- Pour lui, ça a été
une situation très anxiogène
de se faire dire : "Tu ne bouges
plus nulle part." Si on veut
t'aider, on doit savoir où tu es
puis tu ne peux retourner
en Afghanistan.
- Maintenant qu'il est
à Islamabad, le Dr Wali se sent
un peu plus en sécurité.
Hélène LeScelleur et son
collègue, le lieutenant-colonel
Luc St-Jean, aussi impliqué
dans l'opération, peuvent enfin
communiquer avec lui
par visioconférence.
Après des mois de démarches
et de recherches, tout est enfin
en place : le vol d'évacuation
vers le Canada aura lieu
le lendemain.
La famille obtient ses papiers
et monte à bord de l'avion,
mais sans le Dr Wali.
Les autorités pakistanaises
tardent à émettre son permis
de sortie. Sa femme
et ses enfants sont dévastés.
Dans les jours suivants,
Hélène LeScelleur va travailler
jour et nuit pour aider à régler
le problème.
- C'est le jour J!
Hé, on a réussi!
On a réussi!
(rires)
- Le Dr Wali a pu saluer
brièvement ses enfants
à distance, dans la cour
de l'hôtel torontois où ils sont
maintenus en quarantaine.
- D'avoir pu avoir la chance
de renouer avec Dr Wali,
c'est une façon, en fait,
de faire un peu la paix avec
ce qu'on a vécu en Afghanistan.
- La suite des choses dépendra
des autorités canadiennes,
mais aussi beaucoup des efforts
de bons samaritains,
comme Hélène LeScelleur
et ses ami